what about when you get to a point where
you've been with the project for a while
maybe you're trying to find conflict in
the story and there is none and you're
just feeling stuck how do you move
through that how do we move through
being stuck as you just move through it
I mean it's in your head you can't be
like oh this sucks even though if you
know it sucks and you're like all I'm
doing horrible work today it's like you
know what it's more important that I do
this horrible work and get this two
minutes edited then then it being
perfect to me stopping for a couple days
to think about it because when I stopped
for a couple days to think about it even
more demons come in the fear and like oh
is this documentary really good I mean
this is what happens to a lot of people
when they first start out and that's why
they never finished a film it's they
stop you can't stop and you know a lot
of that's part of the article I wrote is
a lot of a lot of you know Woody Allen
and and every almost every director
who's really prominent and / if ik they
never stop it's every day so you just
got a completely ignore your fears and
and even your thoughts I don't know how
any of us ever do that I mean I don't
never do that like I know stuff sucks
what I'm doing you know it sucks but you
know I'm like this is not my best work
but I scheduled for myself to do this
till 5:00 so I'm gonna do it till 5:00
and and or get this two minutes done or
what have you and you know maybe if you
do that and then obviously you're gonna
be much more prolific than just kind of
you know fine when editing a movie or
writing a movie when you have your muse
with you so that when you're so you have
you're always doing stuff every single
day it's not gonna matter as much that's
oh this isn't so good I'll redo it in
the re-edit or the rewrites or
what-have-you or even you know I hate to
admit it and it's something that no one
else probably would ever admit on camera
but you do stuff and you go yeah it
wasn't the best but
especially like in my promo work you
know I do some promos that are awesome
nothing we do some promos that are like
yeah I you know through whatever means I
was I wasn't on my best today or
whatever it's like well yeah but we have
to turn it in so there you go you know
that makes sense it's probably the thing
no one would ever tell you in filmmaking
that oh yeah
sometimes we don't do our best work and
that's okay it's the body of work that
matters so it sounds like you're great
at keeping a commitment to yourself to
like okay I'm gonna sit down I'm gonna
edit this no matter how much it's
painful emotionally painful or whatever
to watch it yes in terms of you mean in
terms of actually emotionally painful or
just in terms of like it's not the best
work well both you know just just like
you know I kind of cringe when I watch
this but I'm just gonna plow through it
and I'm gonna get this part done and and
you honor those commitments yourself
yeah I mean you know I mean you kind of
have to like I said if you stop then the
you know that's when all the fears and
doubts and everything creeps in not that
they don't creep in when you're doing it
but at least you're like you at least
you have a sense of accomplishment and
this may sound really odd but maybe
that's more of a guy thing I don't know
like I accomplished something today so
at least you had that and any feeling of
accomplishment is gonna be better than
any negative feeling even if the work
isn't as great as it as it as you'd want
it to be now and then like if it's
emotionally distressed well that's great
because I don't think you would feel
that way per se you know when I was
writing like the love touch movie or
just working on something that was
depressing and not something you'd want
to face you actually kind of want to
face it because you're like okay this
this might be good that you know if I'm
having trouble facing this then other
people might have trouble facing this
and this might be something that a lot
of people don't really explore so the
other you know if you're having
something that's very emotional to you
it's usually like kind of
of your work you know it's the blandness
that kills everything you know boring
kills creativity
you